let's say we define the random variable
capital X as the number of heads we get
after three flips of a fair coin so
given that definition of a random
variable we're going to try to do in
this video is think about the
probability distribution so what's the
probability of the different of the
different possible outcomes or the
different possible values for this
random variable it will plot them to see
how that that distribution is spread out
amongst those possible outcomes so let's
let's think about all of the different
values that you could get when you flip
through it when you flip a fair coin
three times so you could get all heads
heads heads heads
you could get heads heads tails you
could get heads tails heads you could
get heads tails tails you could have
tails heads head you could have tails
head tails you could have tails tails
heads and then you could have all tails
so there's eight equally when you do the
the actual experiment there's eight
equally likely outcomes here but which
of them how would these relate to the
value of this random variable so let's
think about what's the probability there
is a situation where you have a zero
heads so we could say what's the
probability that our random variable X
is equal to zero well and that's this
situation right over here where you have
zero heads it is one out of the eight
equally likely outcomes so that is going
to be that's going to be one over eight
what's the probability what's the
probability that our random variable
capital X is equal to one well let's see
what which of these outcomes do get gets
us exactly one head we have this one
right over here we have that one right
over there we have this one right over
there and I think that's all of them so
three out of the eight equally likely
outcomes are provide us get us to get us
to one head which is the same thing as
saying that our
variable equals one so this has a 3/8
probability now what's the probability I
think you're getting maybe getting a
hang for it at this point what's the
probability that a random variable X is
going to be equal to two well for X to
be equally two we must we that means we
got two heads when we flipped the coin
three times so that's this outcome meets
that constraint this outcome would get
our random variable to be equal to 2 and
this outcome would make our random
variable equal to two and this is three
out of the eight equally likely outcomes
so this is a 3/8 probability and then
finally we could say what is the
probability that our random variable X
is equal to 3 well how does our random
variable X equal 3 well we would have to
get 3 heads when we flip the coin so
there's only one out of the eight
equally likely outcomes that meets that
constraint so it's a 1/8 probability so
now we just have to think about how we
plot this to really see how it's
distributed so let me draw so over here
on the vertical axis oh this will be the
probability probability probability and
it's going to be between 0 & 1 you can
have a probability larger than 1 so just
like this so let's see if this is if
this is 1 right over here and let's see
everything here it looks like it's 1/8
so let's put everything in terms of
eighths so that's 1/2 this is 1/4 that's
1/4 I can that's not quite a fourth this
is 1/4 right over here and then we can
do it in terms of eighths so that's a
pretty good rough approximation and then
over here we could have the out comes
out comes and so outcomes I'll say
outcomes for all right let's let's write
this so value so value for X so X could
be 0 1 actually we do those same colors
X could be 0
X could be one X could be 2 X could be
equal to 2 and X could be equal to 3 X
could be equal to 3 these are the
possible values for X and now we're just
going to plot the probability the
probability that X has a value of 0 is
1/8 is 1/8 that's I'll make a little bit
of a little bar right over here that
goes up to 1/8 so I just let me draw it
like this
so those up - so this is 1/8 right over
here the probability that x equals 1 is
3/8 so that's 2/8 3/8 gets us right over
let me do that in that purple color so
probability of 1 that's 3/8 that's right
over there that's 3/8 so let me draw
that bar draw that bar and just like
that the probability that x equals to
probability x equals 2 is also 3/8 so
that's going to be that same level just
like that and then the probability that
x equals 3
well that's 1/8 1/8 so is going to be
the same height as this thing right over
here so actually I'm using the wrong
color so it's going to look like this
it's going to look like it's going to
look like this and actually let me just
write this a little bit neater that can
move that 3 so cut and paste remove that
3 a little bit closer in just so it
looks a little bit neater and I can move
that 2 in actually as well so cut and
paste so I can move that 2 and there you
have it we have made a probability
distribution for the random variable X
and the random variable X can only take
on these discrete values it can't take
on the value 1/2 or the value PI or
anything like that and so this what
we've just what we've just done here is
we've just constructed a discrete
probability distribution let me write
that down so this is a this right over
here is a discrete it only takes the
random variable only takes on discrete
values it can't take on any value in
between these things so discrete
probability probability distribution
distribution for the our random variable
X